bonjour je m'appelle anne sophie le
tellier je suis étudiante au doctorat en
communication à l'uqam et je m'intéresse
aux actifs c'est-à-dire au camping comme
une forme de d'activisme politique et
plus précisément je regarde le doigt
c'est à dire un peu supplémentaire au
web que nous utilisons tous les jours
mais sur lesquels on peut surfer de
manière complètement ces endroits là
sont hyper controversé premièrement
parce que c'est un milieu où il peut se
développer beaucoup d'activités
criminelles mais du nord qui est un lieu
aussi où on peut défendre plusieurs
droits humains justement comme la
liberté d'expression et le droit à la
vie trip donc à travers tout ce mois je
m'intéresse à comment à la valeur de la
vie privée en fait et à l'importance
d'avoir des espaces libres de
surveillance